at least two federal agencies are
investigating Silicon Valley Bank after
it collapsed in March according to
exclusive reporting by The Wall Street
Journal Dave Michaels a reporter
covering white-collar crime and
financial enforcement at the journal
breaks down what investigators are
probing
[Music]
PB fell victim to a bank run it was
a bank run and serve the classic sense
where depositors all sought their money
back at the same time 42 billion dollars
worth of deposits slow down of the bank
on one day it's very common for the
justice department and the Securities
and Exchange Commission to investigate
after a big public company or a bank
fails or any other kind of very negative
Market event svb Financial Group is a
public company who shares or traded
publicly and it owned Silicon Valley
Bank the SEC is likely to examine what
the public company said about the risks
to Silicon Valley Bank did the public
company
disclose all the facts and risks that
shareholders needed in order to make
informed investment decisions the
justice department can look at a broader
set of facts their jurisdiction is not
just limited to Capital markets or
public companies so it's likely that the
doj they could be looking at matters
that are a little bit broader than just
how the how the public company worked
technically doj and SEC investigations
are separate but it is not unusual that
the two agencies
cooperate in the end they make you know
separate decisions sometimes on
different timetables about whether to
bring charges or civil claims
the two agencies are also as we
understand it looking at trades stock
sales that the CEO and CFO of the public
company made in close proximity to the
bank's failure so about three weeks
before the bank failed the CEO and the
CFO sold in total what amounts to about
2.7 or 2.8 million dollars worth of
stock
anytime you see stock sales in close
proximity to a very negative event it
raises the suspicions of a lot of people
including Regulators in law enforcement
and they are going to look at the stock
sales try to find out if the executives
had material non-public information that
wasn't known to the market and if if
they had that if they were in possession
of that then they weren't supposed to
trade
the justice department is conducting as
far as we know a criminal investigation
the SEC is a civil regulatory agency so
its Authority is limited to finding
companies civil penalties that is there
isn't a time frame that the SEC or the
doj have to stick to there is going to
be a period here where the SEC is doing
some investigations whether they lead to
any lawsuits or claims of wrongdoing
it's impossible to know at this point
and we might not know for a while
foreign
[Music]